et
[Musique]
non ce n'est pas un poisson d'avril il a
bien neigé aujourd'hui en france 2 à 5
cm jusqu'en plaît alors que le week-end
dernier les français étaient déjà prêts
à sortir le maillot de bain avec des
températures presque estivales c'est
aujourd'hui la neige qui fait son
apparition si certains sont ravis de
pouvoir faire de jolis bonhomme de neige
d'autres sont plutôt alarmistes n'est
fait alors que nous sommes au printemps
les conditions météorologiques sont
plutôt inhabituel et inquiète les
scientifiques il n'y a pas de solution
au changement climatique alors 22 degrés
il ya quelques jours neige aujourd'hui
la fin du monde est-elle pour bientôt
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable gilles
verdez quoique à des phocéens qu'on va
revoir les images d'aujourd'hui regardez
c'est assez où on se croyait en été et
une semaine et cette semaine il déjà
hier soir on a senti par un froid et il
y avait un vent glacial qui arrivait à
l'ériger bon d'ajouter vous sert il je
les ai pris dans la gueule quoi chez mon
arrivée à paris chez oh là là là mais
l'envié
irinej passez moi j'ai chaud je
comprends pas
ce avec quoi ces belges et chaud thé ce
qui n'est je sais quoi c'est qui votre
style de deux garçons ici
c'est bien que j'entends
rose et un zizi grille
autour de l'hiver et de la neige une
alerte pour la soirée à partir de minuit
précisément on attend localement 10 cm
de neige dans certaines régions il ya au
total onze départements pour le moment
classeur vigilance orange à une
vigilance qui est mise en place à partir
de ce soir près de 10 degrés en dessous
des moyennes ça fait 26 ans qui n'avait
pas fait aussi froid pour un début avril
c'est incroyable gilles verdez c'est
hallucinant on parlait de changement
climatique mais maintenant les experts
disent dérèglement climatique touba vous
avez des saisons qui ne sont plus des
saisons on avait quelques jours le sable
du sahara qui remontait la ja la neige
ça veut dire que tout les tous les
fruits toutes les récoltes risque de
mourir fin du monde économique fin du
monde agricole moi je suis très inquiet
aucun expert ne peut plus prédire ce qui
se passera la banquise fond à hallucine
on est ici on a la neige moi j'ai
l'impression que les continents se
déplace je suis hyper inquiète
franchement ça me panique alors
sérialité pas inquiète ou pas du tout
d'abord je viens de russie donc chez
nous la neige c'est un tout normal
jusqu'au mois de mai voir mme adjoint
oui mais ici on n'avait pas l'habitude
comme on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
soleil de fou ayant ici et officie 2008
2013 2018 on a est déjà là l'année genre
à paris avec la banque et je suis
d'accord la banquise ccrht vrai temps
plein doute vrai souci le reste du temps
on peut avoir des doutes le sable de
sarah horizon dit aussi un truc
exception mais que dalle on a tous les
goûts tous les ans on se tape ça et par
l'homme jean lassalle gaillard alsace et
le physique et vous ça vous savez qui le
sac de sarah est apportée en amérique
latine pour faire bouffer les baleines
parce qu'en fait le sable de sarah à
moitié c'est les fossiles qui en fait
après deviennent le plancton dans
l'océan le plancton le plancton ça y est
tu plonges letton oui c'est ça lyon est
en fait non non non je crois qu'il faut
pas s'emballer or ça peut neiger dans le
mayo liposomale on a eu l'année on a vu
la neige tous les ans en grèce en israël
à l'afrique du nord cc c'est pas quelque
chose d'inhabituel non ça s'arrange en
bouche c'est vrai que pour le reste du
climat il ya quand même des soucis à se
faire alors et fabrice toi
oui c'est un vrai sujet à faire si
fabrice
n'y a pas de souci à se faire il ya des
solutions à trouver
c'est pour ça à l'école on devrait
apprendre non pas l'éducation civique
mais l'éducation écologique et il
faudrait une liste que les enfants
apprennent les trente ministres les 30
chose à savoir faire et pour donner des
petits chiffres actuellement ce qui se
passe en antarctique là sur le 1er avril
normalement il devrait faire moins 50
degrés et l'actuel mans on est à -10°
scuderia un delta de 40 degrés chez pas
si bourran des contres 40° c ou cachée
non c'est bon là c'est la culotte de fil
à
celui mort que tout le monde comprenne
que l'écologie qu'est l'écologie
[Applaudissements]
à vous retirer les mauvais coton j'ai
pas très écolo avec mes prothèses est ce
que l'on comprend pas
très écolo avec mes prothèses et
pourquoi alors quel est le sujet même si
c'est du plastique web vous inquiétez
pas le plastique c'est fantastique merci
faut que les français s'intéressent à
l'écologie et l'écologiste
alors y'a bercot les fraudes etc en
scène la reine presque la scène non moi
je n'y connais rien du tout mais je vois
pas en quoi vous parlez
on a l'impression que le temps le climat
se met un peu au diapason du monde on
est dans une société on a l'impression
qu'ils se cherche qui se perd qu'on a
l'impression que le temps aussi pour le
coup il sait plus trop